>>> COVID OUTBREAK IN
PROVINCETOWN, MASSACHUSETTS LAST
MONTH CREATED OBVIOUSLY A LOT OF
FEAR.
MOST OF THE 469 CASES IN THE
RESORT TOWN HAPPENED AMONG THE
FULLY VACCINATED.
THE IMPORTANT PART IS NO ONE
DIED AND ONLY FIVE PEOPLE WERE
HOSPITALIZED.
FIVE OUT OF 469.
THAT'S PART OF THE REASON ANDREW
SULLIVAN ARGUES IT'S TIME FOR
SOCIETY TO EFFECTIVELY ACCEPT
COVID AS PART OF OUR LIVES, NOT
BE PARALYZED BY FEAR.
HE WRITES, "THOSE WHO LIVE IN
DENIAL, WHO SOMEHOW CONVINCE
THEMSELVES THAT THE VIRUS IS A
HOAX OR DEEP STATE PLOT OR A
FUNCTION OF WHITE SUPREMACY OR
WHATEVER, WILL EXPERIENCE WHAT
EVERYONE IN DENIAL EVENTUALLY
EXPERIENCES -- REALITY.
AND REALITY'S THE MOST TENACIOUS
INFLUENCER I KNOW."
ANDREW SULLIVAN JOINS ME
TONIGHT.
HE'S ALSO AUTHOR OF THE NEW BOOK
OUT JUST NOW "OUT ON A
LIMB: SELECTED WRITING 1989 TO
2021."
SO ANDREW, YOU WROTE IN YOUR
COLUMN ON SUBSTACK YOU WROTE,
"YES I'LL WEAR A MASK INDOORS IF
I'M LEGALLY REQUIRED OR POLITELY
ASKED BUT I DON'T REALLY SEE WHY
ANYONE SHOULD.
IN A FREE SOCIETY ONCE EVERYONE
HAS ACCESS TO A VACCINE THAT
OVERWHELMINGLY PREVENTS SERIOUS
SICKNESS AND DEATH THERE'S NO
REASON TO ENFORCE LOCKDOWNS
AGAIN OR MASK MANDATES OR SOCIAL
DISTANCING ANY LONGER.
IN FACT, THERE'S EVERY REASON
NOT TO."
THERE'S CERTAINLY, THOUGH,
MILLIONS OF AMERICANS WHO CANNOT
BE VACCINATED.
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
IMMUNOCOMPROMISED OR CHILDREN
UNDER THE AGE OF 12.
SHOULDN'T A SOCIETY LIKE OURS DO
WHAT THEY CAN TO PROTECT THOSE
WHO ARE DEFENSELESS?
>> YES.
WE SHOULD.
AND I CERTAINLY THINK WE SHOULD
VACCINATE EACH OTHER AND BE
VACCINATED.
BUT THE RISK IS REALLY VERY
SMALL TO CHILDREN.
IF YOU'RE 18 TIMES MORE LIKELY
TO DROWN IF YOU'RE AGE 1 TO 5
THAN TO DIE OF COVID.
I THINK PUTTING IT IN SOME SORT
OF PERSPECTIVE FOR CHILDREN,
WHICH IS IT'S NOT THAT SERIOUS A
DISEASE AT ALL.
IT'S LIKE A BAD COLD.
THE IMMUNOCOMPROMISED ARE GOING
TO BE UNFORTUNATELY VULNERABLE
FOR A LONG TIME.
THIS NOW, WE NOW KNOW, IS A
VIRUS THAT TRANSMITS FROM
VACCINATED PEOPLE.
SO WE'RE GOING TO HAVE TO LIVE
WITH THIS THING.
WE'RE GOING TO HAVE TO BE
VACCINATED CONSISTENTLY AGAINST
IT.
BECAUSE IT'S NOT GOING AWAY AND
IT'S GOING TO BE HERE.
AND THE GOAL IS NOT TO PURSUE AN
ILLUSORY VICTORY OVER THE VIRUS
BUT TO LEARN HOW TO LIVE WITH IT
AND ACTUALLY LIVE FULLY
ALONGSIDE IT.
>> FOR CHILDREN, THOUGH, WITH
POOLS IN THE EXAMPLE YOU USED,
LAWS DO REQUIRE THERE BE FENCES
AROUND ALL POOLS.
THEY SAY HOW HIGH THEY HAVE TO
BE.
THEY LOOK UGLY.
THEY'RE ANNOYING FOR PROPERTY
OWNERS WHO DON'T HAVE CHILDREN.
AND YET THAT IS THE LAW BECAUSE
SOCIETY WANTS TO PROTECT
CHILDREN.
>> WE ALL WANT TO PROTECT
AND IT IF
THIS PANDEMIC HAD MAINLY
ATTACKED CHILDREN, IF CHILDREN
WERE THE ONES DYING, I THINK WE
WOULD HAVE LOCKED DOWN A VERY
LONG TIME AGO, DON'T YOU?
>> ABSOLUTELY.
>> LOCKED DOWN ALMOST
IMMEDIATELY.
>> BUT THAT'S WHAT I'M
WONDERING, SORRY FOR
INTERRUPTING.
YOU ACKNOWLEDGE IN YOUR PIECE
THAT THE LONGER THIS GOES ON,
THE MORE THE RISK OF OTHER
VARIANTS EVEN WORSE THAN THE
DELTA VARIANT.
THERE COULD BE A VARIANT THAT
SPECIFICALLY DOES GO AFTER
CHILDREN.
SO IT IS A POSSIBLE FUTURE
SCENARIO.
>> YES.
BUT WE HAVE TWO SCENARIOS.
ONE IN WHICH THE EPIDEMIC
ACTUALLY DOES BLOW ITSELF OUT,
OR AT LEAST BLOWS ITSELF OUT
WITH VACCINATION.
AND WE HAVE SOME SORT OF HERD
IMMUNITY, IN WHICH CASE WE CAN
BEGIN TO GO FORWARD.
OR WE'LL HAVE TO LIVE WITH THE
PERMANENT VACCINATIONS LIKE WE
HAVE WITH THE FLU.
THE TROUBLE WITH VIRUSES IS THAT
YOU CAN GET FIXATED ON THEM
RATHER THAN THE GOAL.
THE GOAL IS LIVING.
I'VE LIVED FOR 28 YEARS WITH
HIV.
IT IS IN MY BONE MARROW.
I'VE LEARNED NOT TO DEFEAT IT.
I CAN'T DECLARE VICTORY BUT I
CAN GET ON WITH MY LIFE AND MAKE
SURE I DON'T DIE FROM IT OR GET
SICK WITH IT.
>> I FOUND OUT ONE OF THE MOST
COMPELLING THINGS YOU WROTE, NOT
TO LOSE SIGHT OF THE GOAL WHICH
IS LIVING YOUR LIFE AND GETTING
ON WITH LIFE EVEN THOUGH THERE
ARE OBSTACLES AND LEARNING TO
LIVE WITH OBSTACLES.
I CERTAINLY UNDERSTAND THAT.
IN ARGUING AGAINST MASKS AND
SOCIAL DISTANCING, YOU WRITE, BY
GETTING RID OF THESE BARRIERS,
WE CAN ACCELERATE BY ALLOWING TO
IT TAKE THE HELM.
YOU WRITE, THE MOST POTENT
INCENTIVE FOR VACCINATION IS TO
BE BRUTALLY FRANK, A SHARP RISE
IN MORTALITY RATES.
THE MORE PEOPLE KNOW SOMEONE WHO
HAS SUFFERED AND DIED, THE MORE
THEY ARE LIKELY TO TAKE
MEASURES.
IN OTHER WORDS, CALL THEIR
BLUFF.
YOU WENT ON TO SAY, LET IT RIP.
DOESN'T THE HISTORY OF THIS
PANDEMIC IN PARTICULAR SHOW THAT
NOT TO BE THE CASE?
WE HAVE SEEN DURING THE WORST OF
THIS PANDEMIC WITH HOSPITALS
OVERWHELMED AND PEOPLE DYING,
STILL, HALF THE COUNTRY IS
CHOOSING NOT TO BE VACCINATED.
>> YES.
BUT WE ARE ALSO SEEING BIG JUMPS
IN VACCINATION STATES IN PLACE
WHERE PEOPLE REALLY DYING.
CERTAINFULLY FLORIDA THAT SEEMS
TO BE HAPPENING.
IN OTHER SOUTHERN STATES, THAT'S
HAPPENING.
GOVERNMENT ISN'T THERE TO HOLD
YOUR HAND EVERY DAY.
THE GOVERNMENT HAS A
RESPONSIBILITY TO GIVE YOU THE
MEANS TO PROTECT YOU AND YOUR
FAMILY FROM THIS.
ONCE THEY'VE DONE THAT, AS I
FREE COUNTRY.
YOU GET TO LIVE.
>> I AGREE THIS IS LARGELY HERE
TO STAY AND WE HAVE TO FIGURE
OUT A WAY TO LIVE WITH IT.
AND I AM CLEARLY, I THINK IF I
HAD READ YOUR ARTICLE BEFORE I
HAD A KID, I WOULD HAVE BEEN
MORE IN AGREEMENT WITH YOU, I
WILL SAY, IT HAS COMPLETELY
CHANGED MY MINDSET.
WHEN I READ IT, I WAS LIKE, HE
HE IS NOT EVEN MENTIONING
CHILDREN.
WHICH OF COURSE, YES, SO I
APOLOGIZE FORM.
>> NO, NO.
MY READERS SAID THE SAME THING.
I THINK THE POSITION OF A PARENT
IS UNIQUE AND I CAN'T KNOW WHAT
THAT FEELS LIKE.
AND I DON'T WANT TO PUT MYSELF
IN THE PLACE OF ANY PARENT
MAKING THAT SORT OF CALL.
BUT I DO KNOW THAT YOU NEED TO
USE YOUR BRAIN AND REASON.
>> YOU TALK ABOUT THE DANGERS OF
OTHER VARIANTS DEVELOPING.
THE OTHER THING I THOUGHT WHEN I
WAS READING IT IS THAT, SHOULD
NOT YOU BE, SHOULD NOT WE ALL BE
A LITTLE MORE HUMBLE ABOUT WHAT
WE DON'T KNOW?
I MEAN, I FEEL LIKE HIV/AIDS FOR
THE FIRST TEN YEARS, ALL
THROUGHOUT THE 1980s, THERE WAS
SO MUCH NOT KNOWN ABOUT IT.
IT IS NOW VERY WELL KNOWN.
YOU'RE VERY WELL AWARE OF
EXACTLY, THERE IS THIS
INCREDIBLE MIRACLE OF MEDICINE
THAT HAS COME BEFORE.
AND IT IS KNOWN WHAT CAN MAKE IT
JUST A CHRONIC CONDITION IN
PEOPLE.
THERE IS A BUNCH OF STUFF ABOUT
THIS VIRUS WE DON'T REALLY KNOW.
THE DELTA VARIANT CAME ALONG AND
SURPRISED PEOPLE.
WE THOUGHT THE END WAS OVER,
THAT IT HAD ALREADY, THAT THIS
WAS PASSED AND IT'S NOT.
>> LOOK AT THE DEATH RATE.
AND LOOK AT THE DEATH RATE IN
THE U.K., IN ISRAEL.
THEY ARE COMING DOWN VERY FAST.
THEY HAVEN'T REALLY GONE UP AT
ALL.
IN OTHER WORDS, THIS IS BECOMING
LESS OF A PLAGUE AND MORE OF A
DISEASE THAT YOU LIVE WITH.
AND REMEMBER, THERE ARE COSTS OF
NOT LIVING.
THERE ARE COSTS OF HAVING A YEAR
OF YOUR LIFE TAKEN AWAY FROM
LEARNING AND DEVELOPING AS A
CHILD.
THERE ARE COSTS OF NOT BEING
WITH YOUR FAMILY.
COSTS OF NOT BEING WITH YOUR
FELLOW WORKERS.
THESE ARE HUGE -- WE'RE A SOCIAL
ANIMAL.
WE CAN'T LIVE ISOLATED LIKE
THIS.
WE'VE NEVER DONE IT BEFO